the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
today we launched into radioactive decay
and so this is you know kind of what
makes us us in this field right now that
you've learned the general q equation
we're going to look at some very simple
specific cases and specifically all the
different things that can come flying
out of nuclei and the orbiting electrons
around them first I'd like to try and
develop a generalized decayed diagram
what are all the different ways that
nuclei can decay and I had written one
of these up to show on the slides and my
one-year-old son fixed it with a bunch
of markers and crayons so I think we're
gonna have to redo this from scratch so
let's say you had a generalized unstable
nucleus over here and we're gonna start
drawing a generalize decay diagram
you'll see decay diagrams well much like
these I've already shown you a couple of
these like these decay diagrams for
uranium-235 as soon as I clone my screen
so you can see it there are a couple of
axes that aren't drawn on these decay
diagrams that'll help you interpret them
and the first one the imaginary y axis
is an order of increasing energy and the
second imaginary y axis is Z atomic
number so this will help you determine
how we read these and how to actually
write them now what are some of the
different ways you've heard of things
that can radioactively decay or that you
might have read from the reading this
yellow mout alpha decay so in alpha
decay what actually happens let's say
that we had a parent nucleus with atomic
number Z and mass number a what does it
change into
anyone know what an alpha particle
consists of yeah a helium nucleus so
let's just say helium well this will be
a 4 and a 2 and there's going to be some
daughter nucleus we don't know what with
Z minus 2 protons and a minus for total
nucleons so if we were to describe alpha
decay on a decay diagram where would we
write the final state of this alpha
decay new alpha decayed daughter nucleus
to the left or to the right I know it's
like 9 a.m. but someone just shout it
out you'd have to raise your hand to the
left yep something that's decreasing in
Z and also decreasing in energy we would
draw an alpha decay like this to the
left so let's say this would be
something more stable with a Z - to make
that clear and then a minus 4 what are
some other ways things can decay I heard
a whisper beta decay so what happens in
usually by beta decay we're referring to
beta minus decay which would be the
emission of an electron from the nucleus
again the differ what's the difference
what's the physical difference between a
beta particle and an electron nothing
what's the nomenclature difference the
beta comes from the nucleus otherwise
when they come out they're kind of
indistinguishable so what happens in
beta decay let's say we have the same
parent nucleus starting with Z a we know
it emits an electron with no mass and
what else this is just a matter of
conservation of things here yep
there is an anti-neutrino which has
pretty close to no mass and no charge
and what about this daughter nucleus how
many protons and total nucleons would it
have yeah should have one more proton
and how many more total nucleons the
same yep like that and so how would we
draw a beta decay on this generalized
diagram to the left or to the right to
the right it's increasing in Z I haven't
defined any scale so let's just say
that's a change of 0 that's 1 that's 2
and that's plus 1 that's plus 2
hopefully we won't get to today so a
beta decay would proceed thusly so you'd
have some other stable nucleus with Z
plus 1 and mass number 8
what are some other decays you might
have heard of before electron capture so
in electron capture what actually
happens start with the same parent
nucleus in this case the nucleus
actually captures an electron from one
of the inner orbitals and so that in
effect like neutralizes a proton right
in terms of charge so what do we end up
with
yep so we'd have some daughter nucleus
if it neutralizes a proton we'd have one
fewer protons and then how many total
nucleons the same yep there we go and so
if we were to draw electron capture on
this map we would have one fewer proton
so we could have some sort of decay by
electron capture anything else what
other particles can be emitted from a
nucleus yeah positrons so let's get this
list going up yeah so if we start off
with a parent Z and a we know we emit a
positron which is the antimatter
equivalent of an electron so same
general characteristics except opposite
charge in this case we'll give it a zero
protons and zero neutrons and we end up
with well the same daughter nucleus so
we could say that this precedes by
positron creation or electron capture
it's the same process or the same ending
state but can you have positrons in any
possible decay we actually went over
this once
anyone remember yeah so you're saying
your head no
we'll get back into that you're right so
we'll put a little box around this
because you have to have a certain
amount of energy in order to create the
positron and what else what about the
the easiest one what else can be emitted
from a nucleus I heard a couple things
neutrons so certainly if you emit a
neutron there are some very unstable
nuclei like helium five which exists for
what ten to the minus twenty six seconds
or something that could have been a
neutron if we start off with Z an a then
we'll start off with a neutron and a
daughter with the same Z and a minus one
total so what would that look like on a
decay chain you don't usually see this
but we're draw it anyway it would go
straight down right so it'll be some
other nucleus so the same Z but an a
minus one and it could decay by Neutron
emission yeah that totally happens if
you look at the very very right edge of
the table of nuclides let's go back to
the home page for that and look at the
super Neutron rich like helium ten who's
ever heard of this right doesn't even
say let's say two neutrons so this is so
unstable that it just immediately spits
out two neutrons so yeah these things
happen you won't tend to see this decay
in textbooks because it only happens for
exceptionally unstable nuclei but yeah
that's true
it does happen what else could happen
remember we've been talking about yeah
right
it could be gammas and so I'll make one
little extra piece here for a gamma
decay which is nothing more than a
photon emitted from the nucleus we start
off with a parent Z and a
and this becomes well what should I even
write daughter nucleus I see some people
shaking their heads no why not yep
yep so very close you have the same atom
so let's say the same parent with the
same number of protons same number of
total nucleons and I'll just correct
that to say one of its nuclei is at a
lower energy state but otherwise
everything is completely correct so why
don't we put a little star here to say
that that was at an excited state just
like electrons can be promoted to outer
shells pick up a little bit of energy so
can nucleon so can protons and neutrons
and this is so going to be a subject of
well great discussion in 22:02
for now all you have to know is that
nucleons like electrons can occupy
higher energy states and when they fall
down to lower energy state they can
release that energy in the form of a
gamma ray so you could also have let's
say squiggly line gamma decay to
something stable and so this right here
would be the generalized decay diagram
anyone ever heard of one isotope that
undergoes all these possible decay
mechanisms glad no one's saying anything
because neither have I there's one that
comes close actually if you look at no
that's not this part I want to show you
I want to show you the big one if you
look at potassium-40 the nuclide we've
probably talked about the most so far it
covers most of the space of this
generalized a.k diagram and there was a
question that came through at least I
think or non-anonymous email what is it
that makes these even even versus
odd-odd nuclei less or more stable
anytime you have an odd odd nucleus both
the number of protons the number of
neutrons these nuclear shells are not
fully occupied and they're not that
stable compared to an even even nucleus
that has an even number of Z and an even
number of n just kind of like electrons
these things tend to travel in pairs and
not fully occupied energy levels will be
less stable potassium-40 happens to be
one of those odd-odd nuclei that is
relatively unstable and it can go either
way either you can lose a proton or you
can gain a proton by competing
mechanisms like positron or electron
capture
or beta emission so this one I like a
lot because it gives you almost every
possible decay with the exception of
alpha decay and spontaneous Neutron
emission it's not that unstable and you
know only one really missing from here I
found what I think is the simplest to K
diagram ever just prozium 151 there's
only one thing it can do is it can decay
via alpha decay to its ground state I
want to point out a few of the features
of these decay diagrams so you know what
to look for up here is the parent
nucleus down there's the daughter
nucleus and these energies are not
absolute they're relative to the ground
state of whatever the daughter nucleus
is so this is a simple example who helps
show you that Galilean 147 doesn't have
a binding energy of zero this is
relative to the ground state of Gadd 147
and that will tell you that the Q value
for this reaction is 4.1 796 MeV these
things are usually listed in MeV unless
said otherwise you also might notice a
pattern that most alpha particles tend
to come out around 4 MeV or larger the
answer to y is going to be given in 2202
yep these percentages tell you the
probability that each decay will happen
these are usually measured because it
can be let's say let's say things get
quantum and difficult in terms of
calculating these and our knowledge of
wave functions of well higher and higher
a or Z nuclei gets a little less time a
little more tenuous so a lot of these
would be measured you can look at the
number of alpha particles of each energy
that you observe and then you get the
average probabilities for this one it's
simple there's a hundred percent
probability that this is the only thing
that exists the other things to note the
half-life will be given up here in this
case at seventeen point nine minutes so
relatively long half-life compared to
helium five and we'll be going over what
half-life is and what they are on Friday
and then the last thing are the spin
states of the initial and final nuclei
which we will not cover in this class
but you will cover in 22:02 so
don't worry about those now but do know
that when you need to go find the spin
states of the initial and final nuclei
to see if certain transitions are
allowed this is where you're going to go
any questions on what you see here on
how to read these decay diagrams okay
then let's move on to some the simplest
of them which in the table can look the
most complicated so here you can see
that there's a whole bunch of different
probabilities for different alpha decay
nuclear this is one of those more
complex examples where the easiest thing
to do is just measure see how many
alphas you get at each energy and this
will give you the approximate
probabilities that each decay happens
and you'll notice here that the final
energy states for each of these alphas
is not necessarily zero this will tell
you what they are relative to the ground
state of in this case thorium 231 so you
can emit an alpha from from any
combination of nuclear shell levels
inside this nucleus and you might end up
with a new daughter nucleus whose
protons or neutrons are in excited
States and the way you remove those
excited States is gamma decay like we
talked about here so a lot of alpha
decays are immediately followed by a
chain of gamma decays or what we call I
teased or isomeric transitions so you'll
see a couple bits of notation for
example you make here called gamma decay
you may hear it called isomeric
transition we'll try to give them all so
that in the various readings you have
you know what's what so notice here you
can have with the probability still
small that they didn't bother to draw it
an alpha decay to 0.6 3 4 MeV and then
any series of gammas from let's say from
this state to that state and then from
this state to one of those or one of
those and then another one down there so
an alpha decay may be followed by a
whole bunch of gamma transitions or as
few as none if you want to see what the
Alpha energies are well let's head to
the table of nuclides and look at
uranium-235
so if we look up u-235 you can see that
at alpha decays to thorium 231 and I'll
show you the part of the table that I
didn't show you in the slides which is
then you've got a table of alpha decay
energies as well as relative intensities
and what's called a hindrance this stuff
right here comes from the fact that
different alpha decay energies can
happen with different probabilities at
different times so the half-life of a
particular alpha decay can be slightly
different and this is another one of
those really kooky things where certain
energy alpha transitions will happen a
little more often initially then finally
but we don't have to worry about that
yet I just want you to know that's why
the hindrance is there and so you can
look from this table what's the
probability that each of these alphas
will come out and there's going to be
some uncertainty associated with these
this is going to usually be some sort of
measurement uncertainty then you might
also ask why is it that the highest
energy alpha ray is not the same energy
as the Q value so for this
it's a greatly simplified application of
the Q equation that we learned last time
so for here what are the two equations
that we need to conserve if we have a
system consisting of we have our initial
nuclei going into our final nuclei and
they go off in equal and opposite
directions if it's alpha decay then we
have no little initial nucleus we just
had a large initial nucleus at last at
rest and afterwards you've got a small
final nucleus which we know is the alpha
particle and a large final nucleus which
we'll call the daughter product and
let's say this is the parent it's a much
much simpler system than the general one
we analyzed last week so what are the
equations that will use to conserve to
find out what's the energy of this alpha
particle anyone same three answers as
always yep yep mass energy and momentum
I'm gonna lump these two together
because they're kind of the same thing
so let's just go with energy and
momentum so what is the initial kinetic
energy or let's say the initial kinetic
energy of this parent nucleus we can
assume to be zero
what about the final kinetic energy of
the system well there's only two
particles there's going to be some
kinetic energy of the alpha particle
plus the recoiled kinetic energy because
if the alpha goes in one direction the
daughter nucleus has to go off in the
other direction and the total energy
comes out to Q this Q value you can get
by conserving Nath's where we can say
that the mass of the parent has to equal
the mass of the Alpha plus the mass of
the daughter plus Q
so that's where we can get cute if we
don't know it already luckily we know it
already so there we've used mass there
we've used energy and now what are the
momentum of the initial and final states
here anyone just shout it out what's the
initial momentum of the parent nucleus
zero equals what's the momentum of the
Alpha and then remember that trick if we
want to say p equals MV equals what more
convenient form that contains the energy
square root of 2m t so let's go with
that so there'll be the square root of
two mass of the Alpha kinetic energy of
the Alpha minus the square root of two
times the mass of the daughter times the
kinetic energy of the daughter because
these have to have equal and opposite
momentum so all we have to do is move
that one over here this makes that
equation easy everything's got a square
root of two we can square both sides and
we end up with a pretty simple relation
mass of the alpha times the kinetic
energy of the Alpha is the mass of the
daughter times the kinetic energy of the
daughter we don't usually care about the
kinetic energy of the recoil nucleus or
the daughter because the range is so
small that we usually don't get to
measure it but we are trying to measure
what are the actual alpha particle
energies so that we can reconstruct oops
this table down here so we can take our
energy conservation equation and
rearrange it to isolate TD the kinetic
energy of the daughter and say TD equals
Q minus T alpha substitute that in here
and let's rewrite what we've got mass of
the alpha T alpha equals mass of the
daughter times
Q minus T alpha if we multiply each term
in here by M D we get M DQ minus M D T
alpha then we can take all of the T
alphas on one side so we'll just add T I
add M DT alpha to each side so we have M
alpha T alpha plus M DT alpha equals M
DQ we can factor out the T alpha here
and then we can divide each side by M
alpha plus M daughter cancel out the MA
plus M D and there we have the answer
the kinetic energy alpha is just the Q
value times the ratio of the daughter
mass to the total mass this should look
awfully familiar when we did this in the
frame of Neutron elastic scattering or
any other reaction we had the same
equation with just different notation so
do you guys recognize this firmware we
had t3 equals Q times M 4 over m 3 plus
M 4 it's the exact same result just
different notation last time we did it
in the most complex way possible this
time we started off with the simplest
possible equations for alpha decay in
the end it's the same q equation we just
didn't bother what all the other terms
and angles and things that we don't need
so is everyone clear where this came
from cool and that's why you're never
going to see an alpha particle that's
got the same energy as the initial minus
the final energy because the recoil
nucleus or the daughter nucleus takes
away some of that kinetic energy in
order to conserve the momentum of the
system that was initially at rest
another way to say this for those who
like center of mass coordinates is the
center of mass of this system was
the parent nucleus it was at rest the
center of mass of the final system has
to remain at rest to conserve momentum
but again I won't go into much into
center of mass because I find it a
little unintuitive
I'll stick with a laboratory frame of
reference so any questions before I move
on alpha I think is the simplest case of
radioactive decay and think now you know
all you need to know about it yes they
were not not MA and MD but TA and TD
would change yep so in this case for a
different alpha decays they'll have
different Q values so the Q value of
let's say this top alpha decay is this
energy here four point six seven six MeV
minus 0.63 four so use a different Q and
you'll get different TAS and T DS yep so
don't worry you'll get chances to try
out these calculations on the homework
well I'll actually ask you to verify
some of these you know calculate some of
these from this equation make sure you
get the same values as the table any
other questions on alpha decay before
moving on to beta we're just going an
order of the Greek alphabet so beta
decay is a kind of funny one you don't
tend to get a beta particle out at the
energy of this Q value you actually end
up getting a spectrum and this measured
spectrum of different beta kinetic
energies is what led to the thoughts
that there must be something else
carrying away some of that extra mass of
some of that extra energy I say that
like it's the same thing because yeah it
totally is and this is what led to the
thinking that there's got to be some
other very difficult to detect particle
so the theorists here we're saying if we
take we know the initial and final
energies from beta decay and we know
that we get a spectrum of different beta
energies and the probability of finding
a beta particle at energy Q drops to
like zero you'll almost never see it
there's
ought to be something else carrying away
the energy so this idea of the neutrino
or in this case the anti neutrino was
proposed a long time before it was
confirmed and finally we know why and
one of the questions I want you to think
about because it might be on an exam in
exactly two weeks is if this is the
relative number of electrons from beta
decay as a function of energy what does
the number of anti neutrinos versus
energy look like in order to maintain
conservation of energy so it's something
I want you guys to think about but I'm
not going to tell you what it is until
the solutions for an exam in the
meantime what another thing to note is
that these beta decays can also be
followed by any number of gamma
transitions I've given you a simple one
if you want to look up simple ones to
test your knowledge go with the light
elements they don't have that many
nucleons and they won't have that many
transitions for example if we pick a
beta decay nucleus something simple
let's go with lithium which typically
has the stable isotopes are lithium six
or lithium seven so do you think that
higher or lower mass number lithium will
tend to go by beta decay based on this
generalized decay diagram it's what
lower lower proton number well we got to
stick with no number of protons because
we need to remain lithium so in other
words do you expect lithium four and
lithium five or lithium eight lithium
nine to go by beta decay
the higher ones okay if you guys
remember the math parabolas from a
couple weeks ago we delineated where
you'd expect beta decay in order to
reduce the proton number and positron
decay in order I'm sorry beta decay in
order to increase the proton number so
if you've got too many neutrons and not
enough protons chances are beta decay
will help equalize you out so that's a
guess I haven't even tried this at home
let's see let's see what happens with
lithium eight oh look at that
beta decay can also decay by beta plus
two alpha which is another word for the
nucleus just blows apart it's
interesting too if you read Chadwicks
paper again the way he described a
beryllium nucleus is consisting of a
neutron plus two alpha particles
interesting huh
lithium nine could decay by or let's say
lithium eight what do we have beta plus
2 alpha yeah so Chadwick described any
nucleus as consisting of these
elementary ish particles that you could
measure and in this case you kind of see
a physical example when this nucleus
blows apart it just becomes two alphas
and a beta interesting but let's look at
the beta decay two beryllium eight
pretty simple you may ask why can't you
have beta decay for directly from the
highest energy to the ground state
energy that is a 2202 question that I'll
mention there are allowed and
unallowable in and energy states so if
you're wondering why isn't every line
drawn in the case of really complex
nuclei there aren't enough pixels on the
screen sometimes but for the simple
nuclei there are actually rules of
selection to decide when you can make
this transition but a lot of beta decays
will usually be something like a beta
decay followed by a gamma so let's see a
couple of well-known examples for
example carbon-14 this is the basis
behind carbon dating one of those rare
instances when you have a beta decay
directly to the ground state it's about
as simple as it gets
and because the half-life is 5730 years
it's really useful for dating when did
an organism or a piece of material die
on the timescale of let's say 10
to tens of thousands of years once
you've gone past a few half-lives and
there's very little carbon-14 left there
aren't a lot of decays left and your
counting statistics get crappy and it
gets harder and harder to carbon-date
things the basis behind this is that all
living organisms that are in taking an
exhaling carbon by some means remain an
isotopic equilibrium with the carbon
surrounding them and while most carbon
is co2 and sand food and whatever is
carbon-12 you're going to have a little
bit of carbon-14 production from the
upper atmosphere this is usually a
cosmic ray phenomenon which we'll get
into when we get into cosmic rays the
moment you die you stop in taking carbon
and the little bit of carbon-14 in the
cloth and the food and your body
whatever starts to decay naturally with
a very regular decay curve and so this
is the whole basis behind carbon dating
and in the next pset you'll actually see
how this was used to debunk the Shroud
of Turin or the supposed burial cloth of
Jesus of Nazareth because the carbon
dating data just didn't check out as
much as people really wanted to feel
like we found it no science that's the
answer no another well-known one we've
talked about before is molybdenum-99
decaying to technetium-99 metastable
notice how here any number of beta
decays and any cascade of very fast
gamma transitions they almost all end
right here at this state of about C
there's two numbers written over each
other but it's about a hundred and forty
ke V or 0.14 MeV this transition from
this state to the ground state is a slow
transition so you can actually build up
technetium-99 in what's called series
decay which were going to cover on
Friday and then you can use these 140 ke
V gamma rays to do medical imaging so
when you get a medical imaging procedure
done chances are this is how it's done
you get Molly 99 out of a reactor or an
accelerator Technic a toda that
chemically isolate the technetium-99
metastable which lasts on the order of
six days or so very quickly get it to
someone inject it an image where do the
gamma rays go
or what are the gamma rays come from one
last notable one is responsible for a
lot of well problems when folks go urban
exploring an old dentists offices
nowadays they have electrostatic x-ray
machines at dentists offices but back in
the day you could get a little button of
cobalt-60 which would emit two very
characteristic gamma rays in addition to
its beta decays so normally what happens
is cobalt-60 decays quickly to an
excited state and gives off two gamma
rays an accession succession which would
be used for imaging problem is that's a
radioactive cobalt source and if you
don't know what it is and you're like oh
cool what's this blue thing I think I'll
put it in my pocket and keep it that has
been responsible for some injuries from
some folks that didn't know any better
then how do you detect the neutrinos we
talked about the theoretical reason why
they exist let's actually see how
they're measured there's a hollowed-out
salt mine of some sort called kamiokande
in Japan it's a humongous Hall in the
ground filled with water for a reason
and lined with tens of thousands of
highly sensitive photo tubes that can
pick up tiny tiny amounts of light the
reason for this is because neutrinos as
you saw in problem set 1 are always
traveling near the speed of light in a
vacuum so if the speed of light in a
vacuum let's call that one and the
velocity of the neutrino wasn't it
something like 0.999 C or something like
that it was pretty high the speed of
light and water is significantly less
than the speed of light in a vacuum when
you have a material or a particle that
goes faster than the speed of light in
the medium that it's traveling in then
you can produce what's called Cherenkov
radiation which I think I've mentioned
once before it's kind of like a sonic
boom in that you get a conical shock
wave of energy radiated from that
particle that tells you which direction
it's coming from but instead of a sound
wave you get light and this whole
detector is designed to look at the
ellipses of Cherenkov radiation released
by neutrinos and antineutrinos so what
happens is if a neutrino happens to
interact with the water here it produces
Cherenkov radiation lighting up a ring
of these detectors so you can tell it's
energy and you can tell where it came
from so if you let's say cone correlate
a supernova or some sort of crazy
galactic whatever with a slight burst of
neutrinos then you've got a pretty
significant astronomical event it also
led to my favorite BBC headline ever
particle physics telescope explodes
you'd see this on like fox news or
something no this was the BBC what
happened here is one of these 30,000 or
so tubes was slightly defective couldn't
hold the pressure and it burst and the
resulting sound shockwave from one photo
- bursting blew up about 11,000 of them
so yeah the particle physics telescope
kind of did explode they did rebuild it
and it's still going it was an expensive
repair cuz all eleven thousand three
hundred something tubes had to be
rebuilt and if you noticed there was a
guy on a boat there how do you install
them well you float on a boat quietly
and put the photo tubes in and raise the
water level and float to another part of
the Tector quietly and continue
installing the photo tubes until you're
done yeah you don't ya don't sneeze so
ya favorite BBC headline ever thanks
again science for a positron decay okay
we've got about 10 minutes left for
positron decay this is the energy that
you need in order to make a positron it
is approximately exactly double the MER
rest mass of an electron and the
question usually comes up well a
positron has a rest mass energy of 0.5 1
1 MeV why do you need double that to
make the positron because in order to
conserve the charge of the system you
have to shed an orbital electron so the
system has got to be able to lose two
electrons in the process of one
positively charged and one negatively
charged and so that's why the
q for positron decay is just gonna be
remember the symbols the excess mass
here excess mass of the parent - SS mass
of the daughter - two times the rest
mass of the electrons squared to refresh
your memories a bit find some empty
space the excess mass is nothing more
than the mass - the horrible
approximation of the mass so the excess
mass and the real mass are directly
related and these are things that you
can look up just to remind you guys that
excess mass and mass and binding energy
and kinetic energy are all related again
by the Q equation it's probably the last
time I'll say it cuz I think that's
about a hundred by my count positrons
can be used for some pretty awesome
things and I will in the last five
minutes of show I want to show you some
work done by Professor Brian Werth at
the University of Tennessee Knoxville on
positron annihilation spectroscopy using
antimatter to probe matter and find out
what sort of defects exist and as a
nuclear material scientist I'd be well
terrible if I didn't inject a little bit
of materials and how we use nuclear
stuff in 2201 in order to probe that
thing so the way that positron
annihilation spectroscopy works is that
well matters mostly empty space and in a
in a regular crystal lattice where the
atoms are arranged in a very regular
array let's say these atoms have their
orbital electrons the empty space
between is also arranged in a very
regular array and positrons annihilated
electrons to produce well we'll find out
in a second but we're in matter would
they want to live or where were they
last longer not near an atom but near
the space in between so you can map out
the empty spaces in matter in a regular
crystal and calculate an average
positron lifetime if you were to fire a
positron into this matter how long would
it sit and bounce around before
colliding with an electron and releasing
that extra rest mass energy it turns out
if you have crystalline defects but
positrons tend to last a little longer
there's a little more empty space which
is to say there are more places with a
slightly less probability of finding an
electron and so they last longer and you
can measure the lifetime of positrons as
they before they enter the material and
then how long before they produce their
characteristic destruction gamma rays so
if you think about it you have a
positron coming in with a rest mass 0.51
one MeV and it collides with an electron
from some orbital nucleus that has the
same rest mass the positron and the
electron annihilate sending off gamma
rays in opposite directions where the
energy of this gamma is the same thing
point five one one MeV so you can tell
when a positron was destroyed because
you instantly get a half MeV gamma ray
or actually you get two half MeV gamma
rays then the question is how do you
tell its lifetime let's go back to
something that I didn't quite point out
but I want to show you now is this
positron decay is immediately followed
by a one point two seven MeV gamma ray
which is in pas or positron annihilation
spectroscopy we call this the birth
gamma ray this gamma ray is emitted the
instant this nucleus is born and the
positron takes a little bit of time to
get destroyed
so you actually look at the difference
in time between sensing the 1.27 MeV
gamma ray and the 0.5 one 1 MeV
annihilation photons and that is
measured in let's say hundreds of Pico
seconds with resolution of around 5 Pico
seconds and you can then tell from the
lifetime at how many survived what sort
of atomic defects might exist in the
material so if you want to count the
number of missing atoms or vacancies in
a material which is extremely important
to those of us in radiation damage you
can do so with positron annihilation
spectroscopy so I think I wanted to show
you a little bit about how this works
you start off by making a radioactive
salt sandwich you take some sodium
chloride specifically of the isotope
sodium 22 which is giving off positrons
all the time and you sandwich that
radioactive jelly between the two slices
of bread better known as your sample
that way you catch every positron that
gets out so you don't lose half of them
to one side you've got two detectors on
either side waiting so that that's
there's some probability that the
photons emitted are going to go in the
direction of the detectors so you miss
most of the signal but so what
whenever you actually sense a 1.27 MeV
gamma ray followed by to 511 K V's here
then you know you've had a positron
annihilation event and you can actually
count the time between when those things
happened and you can see the number of
counts and get the average positron
lifetime from finding out how many
counts you get every five Pico seconds
for example there's something to note
about these counting spectra anybody
know why they're so smooth up here and
then they're so delineating down here
anyone have an idea you're gonna see
this a lot in 2209 when you actually
count beta particles or alpha particles
and you're counting statistics get a
little crappier this is a log scale of
counts or in this case counts per 5 Pico
seconds 10 to the 0 is better known as 1
so you're looking at one count or two or
three you're looking at the discrete
events you can't have one-and-a-half
counts so you're gonna see this kind of
thing quite a lot when you're trying to
count very rare events and if you're
down in that down in the weeds like this
let's just say your statistics aren't
that good but since this is a
logarithmic scale 10 to the fourth is
better known as 10,000 that's enough to
get good statistics and fit a nice curve
to this positron lifetime thing this is
what one of them actually looks like and
you can kind of tell right there's the
big inside there is where all the
positrons are coming out so that's
probably lead shielding here's two
detectors on either side and here's
another detector to detect that
1.27 mev birth gamma-ray so if you get
those three events happening all in the
right time you've got a positive event
that you can count and last thing I'll
mention is you can actually use this
like I said to gut not just a number of
vacancies but the number of different
size defects you might have two or three
missing atoms next to each other
which will have different positron
lifetimes and you can actually count the
number of each of these to get the
diameter or the size of these atomic
defects and this is one of the ways of
confirming our models of radiation
damage which is like all I do that's
half of our group if you want to read
anything more about positron
annihilation spectroscopy all the stuff
in these slides were from these
references which you can look up easily
on the MIT libraries we have access to
everything because that's MIT we just
buy everything there is so I'd encourage
you to look here if you want to see more
details on how this works and why it
works so because it's exactly ten of
tenna
or five of five of I want to open it up
to any questions on alpha decay beta
decay positron decay or the decay
diagrams that we've developed today yes
what is the most dangerous kind of decay
to be exposed to so in this case you'd
want to say the energy of the particle
is held constant and the number of those
particles is held constant and actually
we're going to answer this question when
we get to medical and biological effects
but let's do a little flash board now
let's assume if you want to see which
one of these decays is most dangerous
we'll have to say constant constant
energy of decay constant activity and
what else can we hold constant well
constant you let's say the same number
of particles end up hitting you that
depends on whether they're inside or
outside your body if you were to ingest
material then alphas would be your worst
because alpha particles are massive and
charged nuclei which means they interact
very strong
with matter around them so if you ingest
them and they end up incorporating into
your cells where they can just get next
to DNA they can just blast it apart
however an alpha source of equal
strength held in your hand would do
nothing the dead skin cells are enough
to stop alpha particles and we're gonna
find out exactly why when we look at the
range and stopping power of different
particles and matter from the outside
alphas won't really get through your
skin betas might get through a little
bit of your skin but not much gamma rays
will mostly go right through you it's
neutrons that are the real killers says
neutrons are heavy but uncharged so they
interact kind of strongly when they do
hit they pack a wallop and they do a lot
of damage and they're mean free path and
you is on the order of 10 centimeters so
a neutron source from the outside can do
a lot of damage from the outside the
alphas and the beta's would be stopped
by your skin and clothes the gamma rays
almost all of them will go right through
you and you guys will actually have to
do this calculation to find out how many
gamma rays would you absorb from a gamma
ray emission and how many go right
through you the hint is most of them get
out so there's a there's an exam
question we used to ask in 2201 that I
was asked during the first exam is
you've got four cookies an alpha emitter
a beta emitter a gamma emitter and a
neutron emitter of constant energy and
activity you must do one of the
following you have to hold one in your
hand at arm's length you have to put one
in your pocket you have to eat one and
you have to give one to a friend what do
you do and why anyone have an idea
pop quiz yeah
that's right I can tell this is the West
because when I asked a group of
Singaporean students the same question
they would eat the neutron to save the
friend because of Confucian ethics yeah
I doesn't fly here your answer is
correct because this is America what
would you do with the other three eat
the gamma because most of the gammas
will just get to the friend right what
about the Alpha and the beta yep hold
the beta at arm's length because there's
another aspect of shielding betas that
we'll get into when betas stop in
material they produce some low energy
x-rays called bremsstrahlung so you'd
want to get those far from you and the
Alpha in your pocket we'll just be
absorbed by the pocket yeah so that's
the right question so you're not gonna
see that on the exam but good news is
you've pretty much got the right answer
because this is America probably time
for one more question if anyone has one
cool if not then I want to remind you
Amelia
we'll see you on Thursday so do come to
class Thursday I'm gonna change the
syllabus to reflect that and we'll have
two hours of class on Friday to get
through decay and activity in half-life
followed by an hour of recitation so I
will see you guys Friday and we'll see
what mood I'm in depending on how the
nano caliber entry goes could be a fun
measurement
you